اينما وليت وجهك او اينما وليت عدسه
الكاميرا في اي منطقه من مدينه رفح تجد
اوجه جديده من الماساه والمعاناه التي
يعيشها سواء سكان المدينه او اكثر من
مليون ونصف فلسطيني يعيشون في هذه المدينه
الضيقه الضيقه نحن نتواجد هنا في منطقه
مواص رفح بالقرب من شاطئ بحر مدينه
رفح هذه الخيمه تؤوي اكثر من ع افراد ضيقه
جدا 14 نفر يحدثني رب الاسره بالكاد
ينامون فيها في ساعات
الليل هي مكونه من
النايلون البسيط مراكز الاواء ممتلئه عن
بكره ابيها في مدينه رفع سواء المدارس
التابعه لانرى او فروع ومقرات للجامعات او
حتى المؤسسات الحكوميه حتى من يتواجد داخل
مدارس الانورى رصدنا صباح اليوم عدد من
العائلات اتخذت من سلم من الدرج درجه
المدرسه ماو لها يبيت الاطفال والنساء
والمرضى على درج المدرسه لعدم توفر اي غرف
او حتى خيام يستقرون بها لا تستطيع
لمنظمات الاغاثه الدوليه ولا المحليه
الفلسطينيه التعامل مع هذه الاعداد
الكبيره في ظل
محدوديه المساعدات التي تدخل الى قطاع غزه
عبر معبر رفح البري سواء مساعدات من ناحيه
الخيام من ناحيه المساعدات التموينيه
والغذائيه بكل معنى الحرفي للكلمه عندما
نقول ان عائلات تجوع في غزه بالفعل هناك
عائلات تجوع في مدينه غزه وفي رفح في جميع
انحاء القطاع نتيجه عدم توفر الدقيق نتيجه
عدم توفر الغذاء نتيجه فما بالك في
الادويه المستلزمات الطبيه 70% من
المساعدات الطبيه التي تدخل لقطاع غزه حسب
المكتب الاعلام الحكومي انها خارج خارج
احتياجات واولويات الصحيه لعلاج الالاف من
الجرحى لجنه الطوارئ هنا في مدينه رفح
تقول انها بحاجه على الاقل ل 50,000 خيمه
لواء العائلات التي تنزح الى مدينه رفح
حتى ان مراكز الاواء امتلات عن بكره ابيه
تشاهدون في الصوره من الصفيح من النيلون
من القماش من الخشب البسيط يحاولون ايواء
اطفالهم ونسائهم وبناتهم لكن وعوره الطقس
واشتداد مع اشتداد الحرب والقصف
الاسرائيليه تزيد من بلاء وماساه مئات
الالاف من العائلات التي نزحت هنا الى
مدينه رفح في ظل اوضاع انسانيه اقل ما
يقال عنها انها كارثيه
للغايه